the financial matters are discussed
and
we have to exclude the public from it
but hopefully you'll enjoy the rest of
the meeting members of the public
first item we come to is number two the
minutes the minutes of the meeting held
on the 7th of january yeah sorry we've
got apologies first
oh sorry
my apologies
have we any
apologies thank you turn from stacy dory
right thank you that's the council
solicitor
um
so the minutes of the meeting of the 7th
of january
i'll read from the bottom of the page
page three
i'm doing it for accuracy first of all
four
five
six
seven
eight
so if we were signing they can now be
signed
take a vote to
can we have that
propose from second to first please
chair
oh sorry
i'll propose on the chair
councillor christie's races have to be
second is there a second uh
yeah councillor christie
you
councillor bushby
i don't think i was present at that last
meeting tom was i i think this is my
first one officially
no you were there i was okay
four
thank you councillor christy or
mr gibbs
or
is has mr hardacre joined no he hasn't
thank you councillor hicks
or
councillor james or
councillor mcgoff not present
thank you that's unanimous chair for
who's here oh thank you kirsty it's also
mr puddy as well
oh do you think hard and sorry mr puddy
yeah almost unanimous for
thank you
um
now
there are a lot of items that can be
raised on that but we have an item later
on for
a new business and i think that's
probably where they need to come up
because
um
several markers will be dealt with and
others won't
so i'm going to move on to item three
public contributions
nobody's registered to speak so we can
move on from there
agreement of the agenda between
1 and 2
this
is a question of item 11 the safety
management system
which we have to discuss which is where
the public will be excluded if we agreed
this
unfortunately i think we do have to go
into part two on it and i would propose
from the chair
is there a second
i'm happy to second bob
chair
thank you mr james
uh
can i therefore
put it to the vote
thank you chair councillor bushby
or
councillor
christie mr gibbs
or
councillor hicks
or
councillor james
or
mr puddy poor
that's unanimous chair
thank you
we come to item five urgent matters i
have none
so we moved to item six
the portland harbor accounts paid nine
i sat down this morning and i
to admit i couldn't really make any tale
of them
i don't know who's going to take this
item we need something
that'll that'll be me cancel x
on the go
okay well
i wish this was the uh final accounts
for every year but unfortunately it's
been an you know
exceptional year um with the passing of
poor and different things so the
majority of the savings that we've made
um because if you look at it we're 24
000 under budget which makes a 106 000
underspend
in every other end of my uh services you
know
i would want to have reported that by
quarter three
unfortunately this is only draft so
there are on costs and and
we have to make sure that all costs are
covered regarding kelly's time and pause
time so this is only draft so i think
that will be you know well i don't want
it to be i'd love to say that the harper
every year
made made a profit of 24 000 and that's
something that paul and kelly are
working on
um but the majority of the savings or at
least half are
always returning of the the the pensions
paul love esther this is
and the vacancy savings of the time that
i covered the role before paul came in
and before paul was officially paul
brown that is was officially paid
uh
there's a saving there of 50 000 pounds
um there are on like i said there are
costs that would have to be uh fired in
into this
this course center um to make them
balance but uh our accountant
had to give me the draft and it is only
um
you know three weeks in into the the new
financial year so all costs aren't in
um there has been savings on on slight
savings on the premises
um there has been more savings um
regarding
the deo gloria came in for sandro jin
which was excellent and that
brought us in additional
uh
19 thousand pound into the last quarter
which we we didn't know about there are
costs that will go out of that that will
have to be
recouped into it but um
paul had to go on a number of chips
which i think was temple which was so
they can get their pilot exemption
certificate so we always make when we're
teaching we always make money uh to work
in our uh
harbor area and the torn torridge
there is also which has been high
identified this year which we can you
know we will be uh speaking with the
oldenburg company is the the additional
invoice that will be raised to them
regarding uh the conveyancy uh which
hasn't been charged before which kelly
has identified
additional to that are we had our five
yearly inspection
um for the pilot boat
um of which
north devon district council paid 20 of
that while it was a sum
that we we didn't expect um we didn't
plan for we
it was brought upon us but therefore
they would pay 20 of that that that cost
as well as the carry forward from last
year on the amount of
um pilot usage throughout the toronto
gesturing which was more than we
budgeted for
last year because you you can't plan for
the future years when certain things
like the the deal gloria comes in so
therefore north devon's contribution
will be significantly more than
envisaged by some 14 000 so
we will top and tail it um at year end
but like i say this is draft um
and uh happy to take any questions
uh yeah
oldenburg
on the paper it says conservancy you
said conveyancy or something
was conservancy then it was my mistake
yeah well what what's it about
do you want me to take that richard yeah
you can do
so
the conservancy fee is is charged by
harbors to vessels using the ports um
it's one of those things to keep the the
structure of the port together um in
reviewing the costs uh kelly uh
highlighted the fact that actually
it appears in the last two or three or
at least the last two or three years the
oldenburg is not being charged for
conservancy so um
uh giving her
so she been
awarded a discount now we could find no
reason or record of this discount being
agreed anywhere um and it's a
conversation we obviously need to have
with the londy island company to say
well um they're they're of course going
to be absolutely outraged and say well
of course we you know uh
why should we pay this um the the uh
i did a bit of investigating with
africom
uh where oldenburg also calls uh an
oldenburg uh millionaire island company
pay full conservancy to africom so
there's there's no real reason why they
shouldn't pay their conservancy fee as
as per the rates and charges uh uh
published on our website for biddeford
um we're just going to have to tell them
that and they're not going to like it
very much but that that does that
explain council hicks
it explains the only question i've got i
suppose is
why is it
only a few years being charged when
statute limitations is certain
uh that is a very good question i don't
know the answer
okay i'll have to speak to to
um sean regarding how far we're going to
go back
with a recharge
right open to the meeting any other
questions
yeah councillor bushby's race
yes
doug
um
yeah yeah i'm slightly concerned about
um you know this
charge to uh the odenberg i mean
i take it it was our mistake that they
haven't been charged in previous years
um but if they're already paying a
charge
to ill for comb
if they've got to then pay another
charge to to biddeford
surely you know we're in danger here of
pushing the oldenburg away once again
and it'll operate just out of wilfercom
and not bother with pity fred
it's a fair challenge i mean the
conservancy is a standard charge in any
harbor and if you look at any harbor
rates and charges um we as the harbour
are required to charge conservancy to to
to make money to keep the structure of
the harbor together um it's a it's a
fair challenge i i don't i don't know
whether the oldenburg are likely to
disappear but it it that the highlighted
part here is the fact that it's it's in
our schedule of charges uh and for some
reason unknown to
us we haven't been charging it
previously and i i don't know why and
whether we
whether we come up with a with with a
way of agreeing with the londy island
company of of
you know not punishing them overly hard
or i you know i don't know whether
there's a uh um
uh
a meeting in the middle to be had but
certainly um we ought to be charging
what we say we're going to charge in our
schedule of of charges which we publish
online
wow
that's all very well which is bear in
mind what i've
you know the risk involved in losing
goldenberg because you know it's all
very well playing horrible but if
they've got to pay it over kim as well i
i don't think uh i don't think oldenburg
you know is a massive
uh you know profit making um operation
for the for lundy for london ireland so
just be aware of that's what i'm saying
in any negotiations
how is it calculated
chair do you want me to raise that
yeah
it's a sorry i've got my hand up as well
uh two points and i can answer the first
point with councillor bushby i know
you've uh council bush but you've always
said you know the viability of running
the harbor because it's a constant loss
um but having put in the resource now
you know
the experienced resource we're actually
finding out that you know we need to
make sure that all people are treated
and all users of the harbor are treated
fairly
and charged fairly so we already give a
free concession for car parking for the
uh the oldenburg and the londy office we
always give them we also give them
the no charge of the harbor office this
is not the case in ilfracombe and it may
be the case that they don't go to will
for [ __ ] and they come to us more often
because the better terms of reference
there the fact that we are under
charging them
and you question the viability of the
the cost of the harbor we need to you
know be fair to all
you know
make sure that the harbor is profitable
going forward
now the the charge is because they work
under their
apollo exemption certificate is that
they only get charged
but previously they've only been charged
25 of the conveyancy which should be as
it is
the same for their political use but in
actual fact there should be no different
uh
there should be no different charge
there should be no distance uh
difference between the conservancy
charge so they should be charged the
full rate on the tonnage of the ship
and i think that's correct paul wasn't
it you're the one yes it is yes it is
what's up for every time it comes out or
or
that's exactly yeah exactly how it works
that the web is chair that would be the
same for any
clay ship that comes in uh future trade
ships that come in um
and also for passenger ships
it's the main vehicle by which ports
raise their revenue to run run
themselves absolutely
fair enough
right
whether there's a compromise to be
achieved about what you know
it's a fair point to say
gosh should you know do we go in there
and slap them with an enormous bill um
whether there's a compromise to be have
is is probably a separate question but
certainly we ought to be charging what
we say we're going to charge
chair ultimately if i can come back and
let me get we could be challenged by any
other port user as into why why it's not
fair yeah correctly so going forward
for this financial year uh know that
kelly and paul got to the bottom of it
and that details it has been a turbulent
couple years we haven't taken over the
you know the management this
the new management hasn't taken over and
run the port for very long uh the
harbour but going forward you know we
will be
there won't be a stone unturned
okay any other questions on this finance
report
mr gibbs mr
just a bit of nitpicking the the bottom
right hand column
it says q2 but it should surely be q4
shouldn't it bottom line of the right
hand column
yeah i think that was definitely you are
correct that that
we will amend that for next time so what
i'd like to do for next hour board
is we'll have the finalized signed off
accounts for quarter four as well as we
can do um this year's quarter one if
members are happy with that
are you all right
thank you anyone else wishing to speak
uh mr putty and mr council christie
mr paddy first
yeah all i was going to say is i think
given the um
well at least i think
that the the oldenburg may not have been
aware of the um this charge
and to impose it retrospectively i feel
needs a discussion between paul
and the london company before
there's any formal
paperwork handed over because certainly
it's correct to actually charge the fee
going forwards but if it's the um
the lack of due diligence from the
harbor authority in the past there might
be some debate about whether it's right
to charge it going backwards
chair can come yes
yeah that's certainly the case and and
and i'm not sure falls down but he will
be speaking to derrick green of the
lundy company um to make it very clear
of the charges of going forward
like i said i will speak to to my head
of service
and the chief exactly how they want to
to look at this
um
but the last thing we'd like to do is
lose the lundi company from biddeford
because it's not only just for the
harbour income and the harbor and the
use of the harbor but for the whole of
the tank
but yes we'll report to members next
next quarter next meeting
the outcome of that discussion
okay councillor christie
thank you um can i suggest we go back
and look at the original agreement that
was drawn up because rather oddly i've
been reading the bidder for gazette
um i can't remember what it was
somewhere back in the 80s
where the original report is and it's
quite clear
that torridge and i i know we're on
youtube now but torrey basically bribed
the old bird to come to biddeford and we
did offer all sorts of inducements and
that may be one of them i think we
better check that i can go back and look
at the original newspaper report but i
doubt it will say what was involved but
i think we should have a look at the
original agreement drawn up
yeah
fine
anything else on the accounts
yeah mr puddy would like to come back
yeah i just want to respond to peter
christie um yeah i was the person who
actually brought the oldenberg to
biddeford from ilfracombe and you're
quite right in the sense that there was
quite a an inducement from torridge in
this in the sense of free birthing and
free office
um to encourage us to come back
and the main reason for coming to
biddeford was that we were actually
londy island was paying rates to uh
torres district council was under the
jurisdiction of torres district council
and as it was quite
uh rightly mentioned the fact that most
the provisioning and trade for lundy
comes for a bit of food
okay
richard is it fed uh council hicks sir
is it is it fair to say you've got a
fairly good steer about how the the the
board feels
i think it is yes you've got to feel
some of us sort of say well we'd like
all our money but we do
definitely want to keep the oldenburg
it's a sensible balance to be struck
very much so yeah
okay
uh next item
is number seven the activity report
pages 10 to 12.
right are you happy for me to carry on
yep good afternoon gentlemen and lady um
quite a lot has happened in the last
four months and i will
endeavor not to do as i did last time
and talk for gosh what was it nearly an
hour and a half hopefully it won't be
quite as long but there's still a fair
number of uh reasonably important things
to
to record first of all so i was formally
appointed on the second of march as the
hull as the harbour master having been
interim but before that uh and on the
29th of march we offered kelly the
position of as deputy whether she's
accepted that i i'm i'm not aware
whether she's accepted but uh yet but um
uh certainly you've got a harbor master
and a prospective deputy harbour master
now formally in post which is a a major
step forward
i have accepted
thank you kelly well done good job
um
very good uh so moving on to vessel
movements then goliath arrived
november last year and she's still here
still there uh a couple of uh
ruffles about car parking various other
bits and pieces but and she's um
we've managed to resist the inevitable
temptation of vessels lying alongside to
um expand their junk onto the um onto
the jetty which they haven't done so far
uh and they're a source of income for us
and long may they remain so
oldenburg came back from her
period of sharpness and i spent a happy
couple of hours on board with paul
jorjak uh their designated person ashore
looking at the level of
refit and work they'd had to do on her
uh as bear in mind she's quite an old
vessel to get her through her mta
inspections um
but she's now back in service
um in appledore the in in yangon uh
disappeared for falmouth finally um
having had her all her repairs done out
of the shipyard the bristol giant uh
remains alongside at middle dock um
she's also a source of income for the oh
it's outside biddeford harbour but
certainly and a source of income for
torridge um they can continue to pay
promptly pay their dues um and uh be
flexible around requirements for surveys
at middle dock and um and so forth
um i was very happy to bring the uh
hopper dredger the ai avocet into
uh
harlan dwarf on the 23rd of march my
first proper docking with a proper
proper ship um she'll be there for i
think she's due to say in about three or
four weeks time um
let's hope that there are more coming
into highlander wharf more votes coming
into the river means more income for all
of us um and can only be a good thing
at yelland uh as um
mr hayes mentioned earlier on uh
unexpectedly normally the dredger de
gloria comes in
in may
to do her um uh dredge campaign into
yellend and create mount yelland um but
uh for some reason she came in early
this year and came in in january which
uh obliged me to go on because none of
her crew had any pilot's exemption
certificates obliged me to go on board
and live on board for 10 trips which was
fun very lucrative for both
uh for the port um
i'm expecting her to have come back in
may i don't know whether that'll be
another full week's campaign um uh we'll
we'll wait and see but uh the last time
i looked mount uh mount yelland was
still reasonably big over at uh the sand
pile at yelland
um
that that's the movements um i'll stop
for a moment just to ask if anybody's
got any any questions about movements or
comments
no smashing i'll carry on um i'm hoping
that the board is still happy with my
sort of to-do list way of dealing with
things um if you don't like it or you'd
like me to do it in a different way do
please ask or do let me know uh this
helps me because it then feeds both mine
and kelly's to-do list as we're going
through to make sure we've got
or try and get everything done for each
uh harbour board meeting um
and we agreed last time to review the
activity of the pilot book two rivers
two just just a as a matter of good
practice to say is she still doing what
she's meant to do and the answer is yes
she is she's uh she's being maintained
every every week um and gets a run at
least every month and this this
particular quarter since the last
meeting she's been out at least four
times so uh from from my point of view
as the heart mastering as the pilot
the pilot boat is still worthy of us
keeping her on the books if that makes
sense
um you'll recall that last time
uh i asked for permission to go up to
speak to georgina
at ilforcom just to explore any
possibilities for mutual cooperation
between the two of us um we had we had a
cup of coffee we had a long chat there's
lots and lots of things that we are
we have similar problems with where
there's lots of also items where we are
um diametrically opposed as the two
ports have different requirements um
it it became quite clear that actually
the the options for mutual collaboration
particularly when it comes to
designated person services and or other
bits are aren't leaping out at the
moment both ports have got their own
systems in place
but i
probably speak to georgina every two or
three weeks just to catch up find out
where we are we share the we share
the oldenburg and we share a number of
other items uh kelly went up for their
oil spill management incident management
exercise uh a couple of weeks ago um and
i intend to just keep ticking that over
uh and seeing how it how it works out
the safety management system i know
we're going to talk about two major
sections of it the mooring part policy
and the oil spill uh plan in section two
but um the other sections of it now are
more or less there and finished and
as we go through the next few months i'd
like to share bits of those with you all
too because ultimately uh what we should
be doing is having all of that safety
management site as a system on the
website uh for anybody and all to see uh
there's there should be no secrets in
there but uh certainly so that everybody
can see how it is that we intend to run
the harbor
um i
just to give you a very quick update on
the oil spill plan uh we it's a
mandatory consultant consultant document
i have to send it out to natural england
the marine management organization and
oh gosh the other ones were dropped out
of my bed
and the environment agency thank you
very much i've had responses from the
mmo and the environment agency and i've
tweaked those i also had some very very
helpful input from from members of the
council from from the board thank you
very much and i've updated that and
we'll discuss that later on uh the the
only the only outstanding consulting i'm
waiting for is is natural england and i
tweeted them last week and they will be
coming back to me fairly shortly
um
our
incident management exercise for oil
spill is due on the 7th of june i had to
tweak that date for for my personal
reasons actually hospital appointments
and the like um and you'll see more
parts of that the planning for that
coming up in the next couple of weeks
um
my my failure and i throw myself at the
mercy of the board um i was meant to
bring you an agenda for uh the harbors
ubis group which we are going to need to
do this summer um uh which i've failed
to do and i beg the uh boards
forgiveness for not having managed to
i'm perhaps a bit being a bit over
optimistic in my time scales um i'd like
to bring that to the next board but we
do need to do a harbour users group and
i do need to sit in front of members of
the public no matter
because they're members of the public do
need to have a a vehicle to sit down and
and speak um face-to-face
uh very lastly uh the harbor office
um we're still
the
repairs are still in in progress uh or
in planning we haven't yet had anybody
to come and paint it yet have we kelly
no not as a reaction okay but but it is
still coming and then hopefully we can
get to an office that is worthy of
showing people inside to uh at the
moment it's a it's a little bit um down
at hills it's probably good um ladies
and gentlemen that that is that is all
i've got for for the moment um hopefully
it was short and sweet i know we've got
to talk about oil spill and mooring
policy in part two but um that's um
that's me for the moment um questions or
comments
sirs and lady
throw it open to the board
i'll mute myself
okay
uh right we move on to any other
business which is where i said i wanted
to go back through the minutes because
there may be things within the minutes
that you wish to raise that haven't been
raised elsewhere
so i throw it open now anyone wishing to
comment on anything
no hands chair no hands
well
that indicates that the reports we've
had have been very helpful
um
the i've got a couple of queries
any progress with
the seven seas and the dredging of
the history
i was uh i was speaking to mr glover
this morning uh
reference standards of of samples and um
it is on my list to do next week so
okay
um
i i appreciate it i i was under a bit of
pressure from mr glover to say you know
what have you done and the answer is it
um
it kept slipping down my list of jobs to
do so i shall i promised him that i will
get to it next week and
you'll see some activity i'll keep you
updated by email if that's okay
that's fine yeah and i guess the same
comment will be made about mooring
policy abandoned vessels
wrecks and house boats i don't know
well i think i think that's probably one
for part two because there's there is
there is considerable movement on that
on that front all right okay
uh are you other members happy to
discuss that in part two
yeah yeah
that's how we'll deal with it yep
um
i think that's it than right
so in those circumstances
we can move to part two
which means that i thank members of the
public for watching in
i hope they feel they've learned
something and they understand
we are trying to do our best with the
harbor
a to make it a viable operation and b
that the public can enjoy it
um can we take a vote now to go into
part two please
i'll propose that we do
thank you chad can i have a second
please a second
thank you
councillor bushby
councillor christy or
mr gibbs or
councillor hicks
or
councillor james
or
mr puddy poor
thank you that's unanimous chair
right